any story you have heard
of skid row will never live up
to what i have seen because we can tell
you a thousand times or a million times
and you can get guys from all over city
tell you these stories you were there to
see this
you would never believe the graphics of
it it was
treacherous and skid row was one of the
most dangerous place i had ever been in
my life
skid row was built on a history of
violence
and dangerous people which they called
the bloodbath
when the bloodbath first started most
people think it was 68
when tuki became the founder of the
crips when he invented the crips
because they say the blood was here
first and the blood bath was dangerous
but it was
a lot before that in 64 62
uh downtown skid row
before that name was los angeles was one
of the most dangerous sites
ever around and i had been a lot of
places i had been in chicago competing
green houston
you know but none was never more
dangerous than la
because of the fact that uh it was a lot
of money in los
angeles and and and it was so dangerous
to when the reputation of skid row got
out
you had some of the baddest guys some of
the most me i won't say baddest or tough
or
anything but just guys that what did had
no fear it was something like
john clock man damn the blood sport well
these guys would come in from other
cities to come and skid row
it was a playground for the baddest of
the baddest
and the most in the ones and intimidated
of the intimidators
you know whoever could intimidate the
other one the most would take over skid
row but the bloodbath was considered a
major killing now when the killing first
started it was a [ __ ]
blood and a few mexican gangs like the
modern bills and the mexican uh
marshmallow
white fish bad boys 18th street
those were vicious killers and they were
uh like my homeboy kicker got killed and
jack looking blowed his head up
like a scan of spray paint it was like
something you saw in the movie
you know and then they they they the
jamaican they ran and shot him up
and it was something like and jack
lickers on fifth and uh
right off right between fifth and
crocker on field between croco and san
pedro
but then they closed jack lickers down
now because so much killing was going on
but they killed the jamaican they blew
halfers and
messed his body up so bad when they shot
him he shot him up that morning
uh and so uh when these guys the crips
in the
and the bloods and the mexican gangs
were killing y'all it was pretty
vicious then drive by them but it didn't
really get
vicious until you got the outsiders
coming in
which was your solo killers it wasn't
going to be in a game
and these would consist of all races
emotionally whites
because they wanted to come down here
and buy their hair when they crystal and
stuff like that
and these guys thought some of these
guys were punks
but people these guys they weren't in
the hell's name they were hailed angel
type guys
and when they came down here you talking
about the bloodbath some of these white
boys
would [ __ ] with messed these brothers up
and they didn't think they didn't know
what they were dealing with
because you had these savage ass killers
they come out of oklahoma
come out of texas uh chicago
and it was something like uh it was
something like a
like a first blood thing if you saw that
movie the first blood
when that man when he went through that
town that somebody told that whole town
up
it was something like that when these
white doors came in the skid row
they would come in here and you didn't
know him and these guys would slap
try to slap him upside down slam him
upside down and that would be his one
and only slap
because these guys would get up with
machetes or and
some of them knew special skills and
they would cut half your body off
so i seen a dude take a dude a white boy
take his teeth
and bite in the side of a black man jaw
and held it so tight he couldn't move
and the dude was trying to hurt but
every time he tried to raise his hand
and scream he would bite harder
had him sticking on his toes and bit and
bit of chunk out of his jaw
and spit on him when the dude fell the
floor grabbed his face he thought it was
over
it wasn't he should have never met that
dude because that white boy [ __ ]
around and killed him right there
just to let him know that you don't mess
with people you don't know nothing about
like one of my buddies told me one time
it was a message with tattoos
on him all across his body and he said
uh he came to me stranger
he knew i get it a little bit so he said
help me i said come on back me up on
this dude
and i saw this big message now you know
i ain't beside this camera i had been in
three or four maximum security
apprenticeships so signs didn't really
scare me it was way to out think size if
you if you had to
but what really bothered me is that i
asked him
when i said yeah we gonna beat this
[ __ ] all the way back to mexico
to the desert bowl and i put my boots on
and got ready when i say what did he do
to us
and do we know this guy we never met
this guy before
and i said i wouldn't have nothing to do
with it because i didn't know the guy
so he went and got another one of my
homeboys
they they went after this spanish dude
and uh this dude tore them apart
and i asked him i say and i said he
didn't kill him but he tore him apart
and i actually might say did you look at
the tattoos some people
had a tattoo so long they made mistakes
when they were young
but they they didn't care about this
they only wanted to be the king of skid
row
and i told them then you cannot have one
king of all the skid row
and so when these bad guys came in the
skid row like with the hotel the el rey
when they came into this in the skid row
thing and they were gonna beat uh
they won a couple fights or they might
[ __ ] the dude up
uh uh uh are pretty bad but eventually
no matter how bad
she was you gotta remember you got these
guys coming from all across the world
chicago because then i heard of this
this skid row
and it was a lot of money in skid row
and everybody was on the take back then
the reason it was so treacherous so
dangerous because even the police was on
the take
they were paying police officers off and
they were blind out of these murders and
and we would make it so when we ride
around that trunk with four and five
keys of [ __ ] cocaine that trunk
of our car
i had i had a friend named b-roll i
won't call his whole name
but his name was b-roll he pulled up to
the park in front julian one day
and the police pulled in right behind
him we was paying them off but they
didn't like this guy
because he wouldn't pay him and they
pulled up behind him open his trunk
and found 75 pounds of weed in the trunk
of his car
that's how open the freelance was in
skid row and that's what brought these
guys in for all that money
but once they got here you had one guy
named hoover jack walk right hit your
pockets like this
see if you got any money rob you right
there on the stack on
on the spot he killed a girl they say
because because he
i mean she killed a girl because she
gave him a's hiv
but now this female did not let
make him have sex with her he has that's
what he wants
and that's what it was back then because
these dudes would get drugs and want to
have sex with all these different
females
but you know a skid row was that
dangerous and they had that much
violence
that it was a lot of disease and a lot
of sex happening rapes down here
at night for the females that try to
hang up here which brings me to another
point
the females is one of some of the
toughest mothers around here
because once you started raping them and
beating them up them girls would carry
blades in their purse
and everything and they would con you
would smile cut your throat cut your
meat off
sometimes they would go in the corner
and and they know you're gonna look at
their butt put booty shorts on or
something to get your
and then they say and then you would try
to walk up to them and talk and get a
date
and they knew you was one of them
[ __ ] vicious [ __ ] and done
them
and then you know yeah baby i'll give
you a couple rocks but but these girls
had them been lied to and beat on
and played on and all this here so they
would say okay yeah i'll get out with
you and con you down the street
in the dark and then once you got down
that street
four five more girls walking behind that
car with clubs and knives and [ __ ]
and you might hit one in the face but
are you gonna hit that one behind you
beating you in the head with that club
how much how long can you take that many
licks in the back of your head that
thing
are you gonna get the one that's on the
side or you started hitting you with a
knife
in your arm and on your side and what
about the girl
that's at your feet started beating your
shin bone and your kneecaps because they
hitting all the points to take you down
and once you fall the ground if you fail
it was truly over then because they
piled around you like a bunch of hyenas
and would have no mercy kill your dead
right there in the dark
like my homeboy cave man up here on uh
on uh seventh in uh san pedro
calling this girl man all day long and
having a tent i'm gonna give you this he
was a big dealer and all that so much
and he uh he conned this girl in the
tent
and and and did all kind of fine things
with him
and gave for a nickel or damn rock after
all that sex
and he thought he laughed at it and
thought it was slick like she couldn't
do nothing and went to his tent and went
to sleep in a tent
not a house with bars on it and a key to
the door
but he went to a little flimsy ass tent
and went to sleep on this guy after
doing it like that
the girl had an aluminum backed with
spikes stuck
all over the back and walked in his tent
while he was asleep
and started whooping him with them
spikes in that aluminum metal he was
there and they found him in his tent
dead
the guy down here i forget his name he
lived off of sevens between crocker and
and
and and uh crocker and uh
gladys he would he was a steez freak
but they say steve made the girls horny
okay might you might do a little bit of
speed it might give you a little anxiety
for an hour to
maybe two or three hours but that don't
mean you want to go and attend center
then and you love chris so much
that you won't go and attend staying
there for two or three days doing
nothing but sucking meat
and getting hit in the butt and coochie
oh and the man won't let you out
he would lock his tent and wouldn't let
the girls out
but he did it to the wrong girl because
one girl he got had family
and she went and told somebody and they
found him in the limb
look at the picture on there they found
him in his tent in a tail like this here
with his throat cut head back
just like that that's how he was found
his tent
because he would take these girls in his
tent and lock the tent
up and when they started doing crystal
with them he would rape these girls and
make them stay there
like they lay [ __ ] because he gets so
horny on the crisp
he want to have sex three or four days
and all day
and you know how well they take your
person putting their [ __ ] in your mouth
but your body all they make you sick
because you want to throw it you won't
let them out and you're sick and you're
looking at this man do this to you
but when she finally got out he met he
went home to his makeup
because whoever her family was they was
not going to tell them and do you know
he had a family member come up and one
dude
and i was walking by his team one day
and i said
and i didn't make that i seen the black
guy standing out there i didn't know
him but he was looking at it and i said
that's a sad thing
man people live and come and die and
skid row all the time it's been there
for many years
the dude looked at me and said well what
happened
do you know what happened i said yeah
drugs happened just like that
and walked away because i mean even
though i don't approve of death
and i didn't want this guy to die i
wasn't going to sit there and feel sorry
for this man at the same
time because he brought that on himself
keeping them girls in them tents taking
one taking what he wanted to take
so i wasn't happy about his death but i
just said drugs happen and walk away
because i don't want this guy feeling
sorry for your brother i know you miss
your cousin or brother whoever he is
i'm thinking in my mind but you should
have told him that's where he took all
them girl and the ten o'clock put the
lock on the tent and kept them in their
regular
just like you love your family members
somebody gonna love bay family member
so and uh and so when all these bad guys
came from all over
chicago which you will know had a badass
reputation come up in l.a skid row
new york philadelphia uh detroit which
is another
another treacherous place came up in the
skid row
and then from the cities around l.a you
had bad names
big names around in the city like big
skillet who's not
privileged for uh um hoover
jack big bunty from insane young scotty
from uh lil johnny from hoover all these
were some of the most vicious nights
and you couldn't show no fear in skid
row even if you knew
you was finna get in a fight and die
both of y'all had guns and knives
you had to come and steer through and
smile because you had to live up to that
reputation
of being there and people would look at
me like they called me stranger
at the time i swear to god when i come
downtown
they say they would look at me and say
oh that's stranger
he was born over there on maple they say
uh they say uh
they really out of hollywood he'd do
hollywood
and they would look at other people
saying that's big spirit from from grape
that's bunkies from insane that's hoover
jack from hoover that's a little johnny
from hoover
that scarf place from east coast and all
these names when they heard this
would get jealous and envy each other
and the mexicans wanted to make they
mark
the mexican mafia they didn't have all
these colorful they had colorful
nicknames
but not as out there like we did you
know
and so uh when they when they got into
the picture
it it exploded a little bit more it was
just tween brothers crips and blood
so the mexicans mother beers white fish
bad boys 18th street all them hated each
other
they was killing each other brothers was
killing each other
mexican mafia was killing each other
everybody was killing
at one point do you know i've seen on
the corner where they had
crips bloods and mexicans shooting like
this here
about all i was on a different corner
the police showed up
and could not get ordered with voice
with mouth
so they get they started breaking out
they [ __ ] bam bam
so you got four people on four different
corners shooting at each other
but now the other three had to back down
because when the police couldn't get it
under control with them little glocks
you know the heavy equipment came in
there and so when they came in there
when they with the big guns
the little guns had to take off and run
you know
and it was soaked it was so much
shooting that it was so smoky out there
that you it was like the 4th of july you
thought you would saw firecrackers
and cherry bombs that's how much the
shooting was back then
but then skid row was wide open
territory
so you got to remember there is no order
like that
like that man said okay and uh and all
blown away
tommy lee jones and jeff bridges i have
come to start a new government called
anarchy
a new order called chaos that's what it
was in skid row and octane chaos
and the police didn't get no order but
when it started branching out
when these white boys started coming
into hollywood the body bodies
taking it back to hollywood and this
blood bath started and they started
defending themselves
some of the people would leave here to
go get the white boys
but when they got over there they
weren't just getting white boys because
you got to remember
you now enter the territory of the
skinheads and the hell angels
so now when you're in hollywood you're
into their area
the hell's angel's been here forever you
know that
and they're they're prepared to die and
kill they would
their legend is born is based on killing
and not and being and not being afraid
of death and then you got the nazi guys
with the nazi strikes with the skinheads
up in hollywood too
then they won against the hell's angel
but then when these brothers go up
in there they would see
that it was like like it's a surprise
surprise
these some of these guys had special
skills they went martial art classes
someone would care of change
and they were rough tattoos scars all
across their face rough looking
and they were nasty and mean and wasn't
scared to die
i seen a dude coughing up blood one time
on the ground
and he was laughing while he was dying
yeah right there lost now he's sitting
on the sidewalk
in his body
and he comes they say i'll see you when
you get there papa
when i looked at this white boy do that
i thought
this man dying and coughing up blood out
of his mouth
and he's smiling and telling his home
while see you when you get there
which means heaven or hell if they do
exist
he was telling his home but i'll see you
when you get there
and he wasn't scared to die so when
these got the guys up today
just wearing these when he say they're
coming up in these tags and
acting like they tough that time is gone
yeah you might have a little isolated
incident here and there
where god should but it ain't nothing
like it was back then drive by you every
hour from the morning tonight didn't do
that
without it
all day long all day every day every day
in schedule at least
i say from seven to ten murders
around the city of los angeles i won't
say just between hollywood and here
every day
mostly all day long all week
in a week you'd have about 15 20 murders
30 murders and that's that's that's
that's the history of skid row
and these guys rise up talking about
they came they might have came up in a
property a hard time
but you know uh we might have came up uh
our parents didn't have a lot of money
or something like that or you had no
parents
or you know you might have been abused
living about your mother and father
or you it might have been molested but
it was nothing like coming out here in
the skid row
how you gonna have nine got 30 guys on
the corner drinking
and doing drugs and all 30 of them got a
gun
or a knife and they waistband big blade
you you you it's an invitation for death
all y'all drinking and we all got guns
i got stabbed right here in hollywood by
a white boy named dutch
we was fighting over over white or over
a girl
a white girl named lorraine who was
carrying my baby i never had children
after that
dutch and them caught my girl one night
and held her down and beat her stomach
to make sure that baby didn't come to
the world
so we had been looking for each other
uh i don't guess he was looking for me
but he wasn't gonna run from me
i was looking for him because of my baby
and caught him in front of a place
called shaki's pizza he had five or six
years homeboys with him
i had five or six of my homeboys with me
and i told him let's do it motto the
mono
you know kill each other hand by hand be
one of his
death so he agreed with that but then he
had a screwdriver in his hand my buddy
told me they got a screwdriver
when he said that another one of his
homeboys came
out forward and then my home before you
know all of he hit me to struggle with a
screwdriver
and my screwdriver was stuck in my chest
because about to pull it out
the blood would have been would have
been
where would have been known i could have
lost a lot of blood so i kept the school
drive
in there like this here and kept
fighting
right so the police was all out there
they might call the police
and i think we blacken each other eyes a
little bit and wanted to do more
and my mom i got the worst in the
vehicle excuse me i was still in my
chest
and when the police got there uh the
screwdriver was in my chest
he grabbed in and shook it like that
when he said to that
hurt like that there and uh he said i
said i'm leaving
man he said you ain't going nowhere like
that there
he said you're not going no when i went
to walk away and pull each other
i say you ain't going nowhere but to
jail if you don't get your head down
you're not going away he's called
ambulance for you and you got to tell us
what happened
he said you're going to talk to us and i
say no i'm not
like that there because when you
couldn't be no snitch
you know you go to the county jail and
so uh they called amland they took me to
the hospital
removed the screwdriver out lightly or
they cut around or something however
they got it i forget
they removed the screwdriver lightly why
wouldn't
it be a little painful but it wouldn't
be as much pain work and speaking of the
county jail
now these skid row was bad but when you
went to the jailhouse for being busted
for murder
it even got worser because the county
jail was so full of old county
they put five and six and seven guys in
those tanks
and if you was not worthy of being in
that tank
they won't try you as soon as you walked
into that this is the kind of just ain't
even a prison
when you walked in that sail if you
wasn't worth them eating
you did not eat we took your food if you
wasn't worthy of keeping people off
off of you like a female they took your
butt
they do and this cell is very small so
six or seven people in there when you
fighting one
i was watching
ain't no definitely right they wear it
out the other end so you can haul a
deputy and all that ain't nobody gonna
hear you
so when you fight this guy in the sale
if you got tired they
[ __ ] you if you lost they [ __ ] you
ain't nobody to break up the fight that
definitely ain't coming down here
and if you try to back off you don't
want no more then you got time you'd be
a girl
or keep fighting they're gonna beat
they're gonna beat you to death and that
sale unless you
if you don't fight you're gonna have sex
and even before that when you after that
when you went to prison
these gang bangers that came up a skid
row
they put all the bangers on one yard
because they couldn't have the prison
was only so big
so now you got the mother bills the
bloods and the crips
and the prison on the same yard the same
people that saw each other
skid row was trying to kill each other
now they only yard killing
until they had to bring that down until
the federal government
went in there and said it won't be no
more this you got too many deaths in
this prison
and they started separating the bloods
and the crips
they had to separate them and the
mexican gangs
some of them because they was killing
any
all over the prisons were more more
deadlier than the street
because once these guys got life i knew
they wasn't never giving out no more
they didn't give a damn unless they got
the death penalty and when you killed
somebody in there
if you didn't get a death penalty they
look at you when you went to court
and say what you gonna give me another
life sentence and laugh
and sometimes the judge would call them
by surprise when they let them say
no we gave you three life sentences
already but what are you gonna do to me
now
we're gonna send you to the death
penalty and kill you alone
and then only then when his face gets
serious
oh you're going to put me on death row
now of course
you don't done this and you keep talking
crazy to us and you and i got three life
sentences
i had a lamborgh kimball we walked in
the county jail
he asked me to do a burglary one night
and i wouldn't go with him
he went to do the burglary so i
i wake up the next morning call his
house and get in touch with i got it to
get in touch with him his sister answers
the phone
i say well larry let me all that learn
he said who i say this at this time this
was another nickname he called me little
d
my name was little d at that time real
short and small but real stocky and big
and shoulder
uh uh and so they say i'll say this
little d
well let me hold that larry she say that
right here
i say what he been out all night he said
no you ain't heard
i said he heard what he said larry got
busted with the county jail
last night and that's when i thought
about the burglar i said god
damn it he did that
okay all right i'll be i'll be in touch
with you soon
and so uh i'm gonna phone up
they had me and at this time all this
was getting big time
larry frankie jones michael mack
and me yeah larry frankie john michael
mac and me
when larry go to trial he come back
crying he say
man these people gave me 154 years
154 years for a burglary
yeah because i wouldn't take the 10. i
went to trial they gave me 154 years
so you say uh we said all of us when the
actors started crying
all of us sit on the bus and start
crying
because we had cases better than
burglary i was in there for a man
slaughter
[ __ ] frankie jones there for a
double uh triple
robberies and michael mack was in there
i think he was in there on a
manslaughter
murder sub too i bout to remember right
all of us know we got some big cases
this man had a burglary got a hundred
so we all sit on the bus and start
crying we said [ __ ] and every one of us
got tired
unfortunately frankie jones he died and
he got in the fight and got stuck in
there
from here from what i know of michael
mack he's still there to this day he's
been there about 40 years 50 years
uh i got out after 22 years and so
uh from what i know about larry
i haven't heard nothing years once i
left for prison
but for as i know with the 154 he still
placed there too
who was jack skilling all them still
there so
when people come in the skid row and you
can never we can tell it however we want
to tell it
you will never get the graphics of it
unless you were there to see
this because this was something that was
so treacherous and nasty
the way they would kill these people
i've seen dudes get to get hit
on a collarbone with a machete and it'd
go right into their meat
and like it's something you would see in
a movie or something you know and then
it would do pull up and try to get ready
and
keep hitting him in the face and head
and everything
and uh the police
five or six police got killed one time
they was chasing the guy
from the la mission and this is when the
los angeles mission was probably being
built
the police trucked the corner chasing
somebody
and ran into this big huge hole in the
military did
and killed them both one
one of them got killed behind the la
mission
many years ago others got killed down
off of los angeles somewhere
right beyond the misery house there was
a police officer county connie back
there
and shot him up because he was such a he
was such a vicious
and i remember the police were gang
bangers too
even though they were the police the
guys they were hiring to come up in the
skid row
with these guys with marines and your
big old
they come out of marine corps country
boys out of the woods
carrying big old tobacco and these and
they inside them on spit
tattoos all up and down there on
badasses
real bad asses you know and these mama
come out there
and the folk like cat mitch would look
at me he say uh
he look at me say uh you again uh
stranger he said
he spit it tobacco take him on an
account in jail
and that's how deep his voice was he's
like
we'll deal with him later this is not
over
let's go and they will take one of you
and take me to county jail
and walk deep in the skid row and [ __ ]
them little riot pumps and [ __ ]
and say uh and
i'm wearing bloods from a whale on a
building here might be no come here
copper we'll kill you
probably hollering back we didn't come
to live we came to die
and before you know it that chopper be
coming up from behind on the other side
like this here
with that [ __ ] long-ass gun and
sit on the side
did then bullets that alone hit your
body and knock half of it off
like you something bait roof or
something they have bullets that alone
knock half your body off and they
wouldn't shoot the kill at first
they shoot you and knock half your cut
take one of your legs when you feel that
pain
brush in the shoulder and take half of
your body from it and feel the pain
and then look at you say you want to
quit now or do we keep fine
do it have you had enough like that
there
and they would break some of the guns we
had never seen our life in this blood
now
and then the federal government took
over and declared war on skid row
there would be no more baby raping there
would be no more kids getting raped no
more
killing every day killing police
officers and all that
and and so the history of skid row
remember was a playground
for i say it again for the baddest of
the baddest
and people from all over the united
states from all over the united states
would come with them with them big names
them bad ass names to come up and skid
row
and prove themselves now some of them
that didn't die and went to prison for
the rest of their life and some more a
lot of them died
because you can't win them all now how
bad you no matter how bad you are
somebody you got another one the next
day somebody want to take their
reputation
you know they want they want to be the
king of skid row so
even if you didn't lose your life
one way or another you lost it because
you wasn't gonna be here you was either
in prison for life
for being such a bad ass killing so many
people
or you died and the drugs was
commendable
and it was like something like out of
spiderman book the kingpin
everybody wanted to be the king female
skin and the gr
office the general leave office almost
forgot
was the most dangerous place you could
go
because now they give you food stamps
and money but if you went to geo office
back then this is where all the gang
bangers hung at
because as soon as you got your food
stamps if you was a nothing person no
gang or nothing
they took those food stamps all your
money they took that gr
check all your vouchers because back
then they should get vouchers for a
motel
you can go you can they will give you a
voucher to go on a motel and stay for a
week
and get you about to eat at some of the
finest restaurants all around the city
and you would get snowball i mean
restaurant service
like you wet pans for it on these
vouchers
but then people when they see you with
these vouchers they like can they come
to your room and sleep tonight okay they
can you help
can they have some of your food if you
didn't give it they took it
they would force their way in your rooms
you know i'm standing here you take your
whole voucher
and give it to the hotel manager says my
about you take your room
it's like that there they take your room
and your food and if you couldn't get
high back then because soon you took a
hit
if you sat down and take a hit somebody
come across you when they know you get
spooked on the crack
they come across you with hogs they
cover their fists all pipe
and bam knock your butt trying to knock
your brains out
or you when you see them walk up on you
you get screwed you sitting there
hitting
and they be scared they reach down and
grab it
what they want it from you because they
know you were scared you couldn't move
if you
said something or try to stop that's
when they knock your brains out
well they thought they could scare you
and you wouldn't move you was high
and you'd be literally just reach down
and grab your [ __ ] and turn and walk
away
and leave you there
so my point was this any story you have
heard
of skid row will never live up
to what i have seen because we can tell
you a thousand times or a million times
and you can get guys from all over here
tell you these stories unless you were
there to see
this you would never believe the
graphics of it
it was treacherous and skid row was one
of the day most dangerous player i'd
ever been in my life
and when i say that you gotta remember
anybody had been to houston back in the
70s uh 70s or the 80s
they had a theater called majestic
theater downtown
where they were killing like a mountain
mother in houston texas
but it was never tough as la
it was in louisiana that was where they
came one of the murder couples of
the united states but it was never a
tougher skid row
and i was in jail in louisiana house of
d where he did some of the same type of
thing they did in l.a you had to fight
for your food
but then when i was thinking i went
through i went through competing green
in chicago
just a youngster tyler i was probably
about 10
15 years old then or something somewhere
between 10 and 15.
and it was dangerous but i had never
seen nothing like i seen a skid row
these guys had ak-47s oozies
and they would stand in the middle of
the street and do they business right
there
broad daylight night day
it didn't matter you know and the police
they wasn't going to take with you they
would try to take them down
and some of them would get took down but
like i say then they would bring that
and the ones that was on the take would
turn a blind eye to it
it was like bad bad leeway bound some of
the toughest of the tough died
got beat down got [ __ ] up and they
want a few when they came up in here
but then none of them last very long
because all of a sudden
every time you get in the fight you make
a mistake look somewhere else
forget to do something and once you look
somewhere else and forget to do that the
person you fighting against capitalize
an opportunity to hit you across your
face with a knife stab you and shoot you
down or something
you know and so yeah skid always it was
very one of the best
that's what i had to say man did these
guys are coming up telling you today
they weren't there and to notice to not
someone that have seen this
they'd have to be in their 60s
maybe they very very late 50s
older and the gang and then another
thing see the young gangbangers coming
up today
when they tell you they're in a gang
member got to be in the game no they
don't
they sag but do you know 10 years 20
years ago 30 years ago
if you got caught with your pants
hanging down below your waistline
the uh any gang mate would say what hood
you from
if you weren't from a neighborhood and
then you checked when you jumped claim a
neighborhood
then they would contact somebody from
that neighborhood
and they said they didn't know you they
would beat your ass and make you pull
your fans up
because it was something like the marine
corps you had to be worthy
to be in the game which means you had to
be jumped in
they don't know if you're gonna turn on
them they get in the fight and they get
about to die you're gonna turn and run
and snitch on them or what
so they made you prove yourself worthy
of being in this game
so these guys today this sagging don't
have no challenge ain't nobo jumping
in they just wake up one day and just
start sagging
and say i'm a gangbanger ain't nobody
that they don't force them to be no gang
of no mode
back then in the neighborhood you had to
be a gang
man because these dudes show up at your
door
force you to be in a game make you be in
the game
get tattoos and if you didn't they shoot
your house up at night drive by
shoot your house up at night or mess
with the women folks in your house or
the kids
so yes you had to be a banger i come up
in that neighborhood
and uh you know i found i saw my brother
they made me be a bank i had to be a
banker save my life
save my family because if you won the
bank of these guys came
at you tear your house up
put pressure on you until you became a
banker
for their protection but how well could
they protect you
because they will steal drive-bys every
day you hit me i'm gonna do your
neighborhood you do whatever do your
neighborhood
and they would ride by shooting each
other neighborhood killing
sometimes innocent people kids and women
standing on bus stops and stuff like
that
it was dangerous so
there you have it people skid row is a
danger what it was and it is
and still can be in many ways a
dangerous dangerous
place but skid road was the playground
of the baddest of the batters
and and they came from miles around
to earn their earn their name and and
earn their reputation
a lot of them died to do that this is
nothing
compared to things i have seen in my
life
you know and so uh all it was about
was people just running around being
wild stupid
and crazy and let me say this here even
though we had to look brave
act brave and smile because we thought
we were the baddest of the baddest
we all were scared inside we were scared
to death
that we had won the fight the day before
and we'll lose this one today
and even if we didn't get in the fight
the very next day
we all looked at each other when one of
us got killed or died
and said how long will i make it how
many
when is my turn coming to die
because you knew you had a turn company
as you see all your homeboy your friends
go out like that
you just wonder when your terms come but
you do everybody has one coming
so i'm just saying you bad ass
[ __ ] out there
it's another one you gonna run into
eventually have a good day
that's skid row stories and that's what
really happened that's the truth